on peut constater en effet que même si
moi-même j'en ai été surpris
ce qu'on retient devant un écran
et de meilleure qualité et plus durable
que ce qu'on retient devant un prof
toutes les expériences qui ont été
faites jusqu'à présent le montre
si on utilise des bonnes techniques
d'enseignement devant l'écran ça peut
être extrêmement efficace
je prendrai juste un exemple qui m'a qui
me fascine en ce moment qui est très
intéressant
TikTok est considéré comme le diable
absolu il est pour beaucoup et je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure mais on voit
apparaître tant aux États-Unis et aussi
en France un
usage pédagogique de Tik Tok et de
technique voisine qui est le suivant
les élèves de
première ou de terminale
qui ont bien appris un théorème le
mettre en ligne dans une vidéo deux
minutes 30 ou une minute trente
et aux États-Unis et ça vient maintenant
en France certains influenceurs de ce
genre sont un pédagogue qui enseigne à
leur père payèrent ont jusqu'à 10 à 12
millions de de gens qui suivent leur
enseignement et on a maintenant
pratiquement couvert en matière de
partie toc ou par des techniques
voisines la totalité du programme de en
France de première et de terminale
où ce sont les élèves qui enseignent
leur camarades
donc on voit l'enseignement coopératif
l'enseignement de Pierre des nouvelles
méthodes je donne d'autres exemples de
d'expérience pédagogiques qui marchent
bien
jeunes professeur de philo que je suis
depuis des années qui est à Drancy qui
s'appelle Jérémy fontagnieu qui a dansé
l'ancienne la philo il s'est mis comme
objectif d'avoir
100% de mention très bien au bac dans sa
classe
il est parvenu avec en particulier une
technique très simple il envoie tous les
soirs un sms personnalisé à chaque
parent
au début les parents disaient c'est pas
le sujet etc
et ça marche son expérience est
maintenant très développée plus une
centaine d'enseignants qui font ça il y
a des racines qui est fait sur lui en ce
moment ce qui est dit qu'il y a beaucoup
d'expérience et dans lequel la
communauté éducative parent enseignant
nouvelles technologies périscolaire va
jouer un rôle très important je citer
ces deux exemples pour montrer que les
technologies peuvent être extrêmement
utile lorsqu'on les encadre d'une façon
efficace